all right come on everybody come on in
let's go let's go free candy I brought
candy okay everybody great everybody
welcome to the first annual company
guests Oh ween costume parade
[Music]
okay now let's let these festivities
begin come on up who's first
here we go and now why don't you tell
everybody your name okay but maybe some
people don't know how are you okay okay
a lovely Rebecca just as rosie the
riveter stay riveting madad Wow
wonderful great Oh looks like we got a
storm a-brewin Cap'n Jack Sparrow sorry
we don't have any alcohol here cool okay
so don't know why but what is rum gone
Captain Jack Sparrow
Oh and now we have the illustrious and
beautiful teacher Campbell from Oscar
night I'm pretty sure she's Cinderella
what no Cinderella's white gloves are
missing Zarrella wears blue okay moving
on moving on thank you very much okay
here we go
Winston Churchill nice mm don't fight me
in the streets Ryu from Street Fighter
huh haha sorry sorry oh wow I love this
tape Michelle Yeoh on the heroic trio
what yes I love seeing a younger
generation embrace the classics no
impossible that movie came out in 93
she's younger than that ruff
you can't trick this treater okay I
think I know my 90s kung-fu movies
okay let's get our next contestant up go
ahead okay another modern take on a
classic although I am having a little
trouble finding you please the
influential and always in the wrong part
of town is Don Black Waldo
hey okay sorry african-american Waldo
come on man how can you not see you're
being racist right now that's him I am
NOT racist first of all I'm the boss
second of all I hired almost all the
races okay well I'm Waldo no need for
the distinction but you're black and
you're Waldo right but you didn't call
Tim white Ryu I don't see your point
Ray's Japanese I guess but look at him I
mean he looks just like him we get it
yeah and I look just like Waldo we
didn't think about race when we got our
costumes so why bring it into our title
okay okay I think you're playing the
race card a little heavily here so maybe
we should all just go back to work and
cool out for the rest of the day okay
who just says what come on I'm shaft
from the cult classic shaft you of all
people had to have seen shaft what what
all right nobody gets any candy I'm
taking this back home
[Music]
I think that went great
[Music]